une production du studio sf
bio sans filtre représenté par kiss me
le podcast on parle de ce qu'on veut que
nos invités d'un super chic enfin avec
moi bigidi d'elle d'hommes
dividendes en
caisse il vient tout juste de lancer
leur nouvelle campagne d'air toubib old
days to be blood c'est oser être
audacieux c'est plein d'action que
caisse me prenne entre autres plantes et
des arbres donner à des organismes de
charité
travaille avec des artistes émergents
être inclusif dans leur approche
invoquée c'est avec vous tout le temps
et pour présent dans le cadre du
lancement de cette campagne la kiss me
offre un concours écouter ce que c'est
un voyage pour deux personnes dans la
ville canadienne de votre choix avions
hôtels et activités audacieuse payer une
valeur de 5000 $ pour participer vous
n'avez qu'à aller sur la page facebook
ou instagram de kasmi et de suivre les
indications
c'est super facile et en plus vous
voulez me commander n'importe quel
produit qui se mue en un code promo pour
ou qui le sf 15 pour 15 % de rabais sur
toutes vos commandes des semis cette
semaine dont
cette semaine on à l'envi par un podcast
toutes les deux points why not pourquoi
pour faire ce qu'on veut ce n'est pas de
casque mais effectivement
s'entendait pas ce parce que on sidibé
tant que les gens vont aimer ce puits si
vous aimez sobre côté qu'on va faire
d'autre on est parti une thématique on
avait apporté un sujet en fait on fait
un pas de retour sur
l'épopée des ph et l'odyssée de phb son
marathon
on a parlé d'atteinte d'objectifs de
l'importance de se fixer des objectifs
dans ledit l'importance d'avoir un plat
importance dans d'être rigoureux d'être
constant surtout la constance au sort et
c'est important ça que c'est une
discussion comme ça je suis juste les
deux sets sur ces thèmes là je pense que
ça vous intéresse notamment ben
dhifallah par ce qui est en découvrir un
peu plus sur nous ben oui pourquoi pas
qui sait que si vous aimez sur des
commentaires à part si vous avez
n'importe quoi laisser leurs
commentaires justement dit
puis c'est ce potager début d'une grande
aventure peut-être pour
l'avenir nous le dira fait qu on va les
remercier vos commanditaires sans qui
rien ne serait possible
[Musique]
le podcast est présenté par tony slip
vous les connaissez ils sont avec nous
depuis longtemps ils sont pas justes
avec nous sont avec occupation double
6-1 et fier partenaire d'occupation
double et les candidats
qui battent leurs stations de péage en
règle police me persécute pas sans doute
cette année y aucune des caisses qui
manque c'est incroyable moi je suis un
grand fan c'est vrai qu'on en forme
parce qu'ils dorment bien sûr leur
oreiller et leur match la police lit
pour donner de bon la bonne bizzbee deux
jours c'est incroyable alors qu'audi
slip offre plus de sport beaucoup plus
de sports avec le contour de soutien
intégré saphique vos
bordeaux i qui la mousse mémoire en tête
ne s'affaisse peau alors ça vous donne
un bon support long ballon support
partout dans votre corps peut importe où
vous êtes positionnés dans vos clips un
pentagramme grosseur de la cli c'est
vraiment super il ya aussi une mousse
anti microbiennes monsieur quelqu'un qui
est allergique gambie pikin mon matelas
rempli microbrasserie rempli d'acariens
je souffre d'allergies assez sévère puis
là pour éviter en fait de vivre seul la
mousse anti microbiennes police lui
vient simplement tu es dans votre
routine sommeil il vous avez 100 du
décès ça veut dire que si vous vous
laissiez 99 nuit plaques à vent et de la
santé un peu d'âge pas sûr mais ils
viennent rechercher votre matelas fait
que vous avez idéalement rien à perdre
que mon code promo pour les autres que
le s2 qui le pardon le filtre 25s 25
filtre et 25 en un mot pour 25 cents de
rabais sur les produits police l'a fait
qu'à aller voir ce merci police lit le
paquet de cette semaine et présenté par
nos amis chez mindscape entre vous les
connaissez on savait parler souvent mots
depuis que j'ai parlé du parfum we find
de chez mindscape nombre nombre de
feuilles qui m'ont écrit que leurs
chemins s'étaient procuré le parfum même
skype que là il y avait la difficulté à
ce qu'on lire qu'écouter un film collet
l'un sur l'autre que c'est pour
leur bétail pc pour s'imaginer ce que
moi ça mais bref le parfum je peux pas
en parler à ces mots je l'adopté puis
les gens qui me connaissent qu'un qui
sans cette odeur là ils disent à son ph
c'est incroyable sinon évidemment le
préfet ctaq 4.0 dom par le module petit
package là dedans les avait tous besoin
pour être rude surtout le lower 4.0
quittant réseau électrique qui le
meilleur le meilleur sur le marché le
meilleur que j'ai jamais utilisé du
moins il y est waterproof dame était
dans la douche faite aux affaires du
sculpteur la pilosité de la région qui
t'intéresse puis vraiment sa faim job
incroyable une technologie skin save qui
nous empêche de vous [ __ ] les bars où
la peau du cou et il est exposé cool moi
je ferais pas mal de petites pauses
repas de petits c'est vraiment super il
ya donc produit aussi pour l'entretien
de vos bases comme un déodorant pour
base un tour nous propose cette fois le
moment mais on les adore j'ai manqué
baisse et que c'est des produits pour
bon mais c'est
puis les gens nous écrivent souvent même
en privé c'est ça marche tu vraiment
magique et moi même skype le juger
géraud battre pour les autres c'est
vraiment des bons produits comme tu
n'entres réellement votre vie ouais pas
encore vraiment pour vous guérir sans
filtre en un mot 20% le rabais le
shipping gratuit vous avez aucune raison
aucune excuse pour ne pas vous procurer
des produits
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hier où hier
quelque chose d'un peu différent
aujourd'hui oui juste nous deux ouais
c'est cool c'est qu est ce qu barrios
attendait qu'on fasse il prétendait
qu'on fasse ben ça fait longtemps qu'on
en parle ça fait longtemps qu'on se dit
que des fois de faire un genre de petit
épisode où est ce que on
parle de quelque chose convient mais
tombe qu'on est capable de les
extrapoler pour aller toucher
l'universel un petit peu
puis aussi de réfléchir pour être sur
certaines affaires qu'on a discuté dans
les podcasts qui viennent parce que les
gens qui écoutent pas sans filtre
semaine après semaine vous avez pas
vraiment sensiblement les mêmes
raisonnements que nous autres au
quotidien au sens où un mois qui a
confiné aux podcasts et j'y repense
longtemps le saiper pense à ce qui s'est
dit puis ça fait un cheminement dans ma
tête puis je pense que des fois de faire
un genre de petit oui cab entre le monde
voudra commentaires si c'est quelque
chose que vous voulez mais aussi
parce que j'ai eu beaucoup de demandes
suite à mon marathon puis un monde 80 km
ou du moins ma tentative à 80 km au
litre de bromont pour faire genre de huy
cap des derniers mois fake je me suis
dit que le podcast une belle façon de
faire ça mais c'est aussi une belle
façon d'aller chercher comme je disais
de quoi qui plus que juste l'expérience
imprécise de courir un marathon
maintenant fait que fixer sur le fond je
veux juste qu'on jase dessus qu'on parte
des bleus pour aller plus loin qui sont
une des affaires que je voulais qu'on
touche dans ce n'est pas comme en convoi
rappeler ceux encore sans fil podcast
aguets
c'est le
le fait de se mettre des objectifs sur
le long terme sur le moyen long terme le
ton puis la sensation que ça procure d
accomplir
puis qu'est-ce que ça fait un chemin et
mettons d'avoir des objectifs clairs
précis que tu énonce aussi
à toi oui mais à ton entourage aussi si
je me rappelle l'histoire de michael
phelps qui de 2004 à 2 8 pour se
préparer les olympiques qui avait écrit
ses objectifs sur le plafond de sa
chambre fait qu'à chaque fois qu'ils se
lever le matin il les voyait
ça peut sembler intense quand même sauf
que je pense
que c'est une excellente façon de se
porter garant de ses objectifs et libres
dans son que je dois ça prend l'objectif
le plus intense que la manière plus
intense de se rappeler pour atteindre le
niveau le plus intense - sens que son
intensité
à l'omni
exact c'est exact pied un petit
évidemment c'est un exemple extrême d'un
gars qui est quand même le meilleur de
tous les temps dans ce qui est fait mais
je pense que ça peut s'appliquer
vraiment à tout le monde a son propre
niveau au dessus fake bref - bloc bleu à
peu près quatre mois et demi j'ai décidé
de m'entraîner de faire un plan
d'entraînement de quatre mois pour
essayer de courir trois heures au
marathon initialement attendu même si
transformée en marathon du
fjord-du-saguenay
puisque quatre mois le c'était un
programme complet que j'avais qui
étaient 112 jours de d'entraînement et y
avait des journées off là dedans mais
c'était sans du jour j'ai pris la
décision de le montrer sur les réseaux
sociaux devant quand même tribune
considérable
parce que
je voulais le terme en français pour
raconter belletti je sais pas exactement
c'est quoi mais je voulais me porter
garant de cet objectif le fait que je
voulais que tout le monde voit que
j'avais cet objectif lui qui à chaque
fois que je remettais en doute mettons
le parcours pour y arriver
j'allais avoir en tête le fait que je
m'étais exposés à tout le monde
puis moi ç'a toujours été cette façon là
que j'ai fonctionné ça a toujours été en
disant aux efforts qui est ce que je
voulais faire comme ceux qui admettons
ce genre je retourne à ma carte de
natation quand ça me tentait pas de me
lever le matin et mais je me rappelais
que j'avais dit à tout le monde que je
voulais gagner
six médailles aux championnats canadiens
et aux championnats québécois
universitaire je me rappelle que je
voulais j'avais à tout le monde que
pourrait être la clé de l'année du
réseau du sport étudiant du québec
j'avais dit à tout le monde que je
voulais faire x ou y affèrent fait quand
sam tente des produits allégés allés là
car la motivation était une journée
moins forte parce que ça arrive tout le
point bas il y aussi
karabatic est il que tu le dis que cet
exposé ce ça ça leur donne le petit hic
de plus qui fait que cette journée le
cèdre est patente et qui va parler - moi
tu y mets ton quand je vaux au crossfit
il faut je m'inscris suscite le puits
dit acquis mardi matin un proche de
voter qui jamais une fois je me suis
inscrit plus parler ouais jamais parce
que tu t'inscris parce que je m'en
branle en place de quelqu'un parce qu'il
est écrit s'essaye à un nombre limité
place j'ai un nombre limité de croo que
je peux faire aussi
mon inscription avoue quelque chose puis
aussi je dirais seb le coach et le vu le
médecin ce matin puis le vue qui vit il
voit qui vient pas aussi tentant d'y
aller tout le tapis je suis content d'y
aller mieux
n'empêche qu'à ce moment des fois que ça
a été une motivation de plus de 10 ce
pauvre et que je veux m'en remets d'un
script l'europe est à l'étroit exact
pied tandis quelqu'un que je vous devine
tout seul ça se peut que tu as plus que
j'y aille pas parce que je suis 104
exact puis ça m'amène exactement où est
ce que où est ce que je m'en allais au
sens où la motivation interne devrait
pas être la chose principale puis c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut insister c'est en
tant que société parce que l'on parle de
sport mais ça peut être dans n'importe
quoi tu mets ton comprendre le podcast
on s'est dit au début qu'on voulait
faire une épisode un épisode par semaine
à toutes les semaines mais je te
garantis que autant toi que moi trois
corps du temps ça nous tente il ya des
fois que ça me tente paul et des fois
que ça ne prenne pas de venir ici des
fois qu'on est moins citées par par x ou
y conversation ou xy sujet mais qu on
vient parce que on s'est exposé nous on
sait donner envers nous-mêmes cet
objectif là mais aussi quand on se dit
ballos finalement t'es chez que si tous
pour toi ou moi si on ce qui est une
semaine c'est correct et sauf que l'on
s'est exposé aussi avec
fierté jamie skeen semaine infections ce
qui donne une semaine
c'est ça exact sauf que la motivation
interne vient dans la plupart du temps
sauf que cette espèce de désir le
d'exposer c'est quoi ton objectif ça
fait les fois où s attendent pas suivre
mais c'est pour ça aussi que sexy pour
beaucoup c'est plus fun puis plus
motivant s'entraîner en gros tu mets ton
parent parce que l'aspect social
deuxièmement parce que justement le
titre si tu te motive à gagner puis le
fait d'abord les autres ça de motifs et
automotive les autres vice versa pitel
la course un sport qui s'ouvre à une
équipe de course métier souvent c'est
très solide et sur l'actuelle sûr que
tout est quand même réussi
où tu as quand même rendu sur la sphère
de gagne justement en exposant ses
réseaux sociaux puisqu'elle monde te
suis qu'est ce que tu fais que ça
devient rare de gagner même si c'est
exact c'est exactement
bref j'ai fait les quatre mois
ouais ce que j'ai à tous les jours
parler sur les réseaux sociaux les fois
où est ce que je leur montrais pas
c'était des journées de repos il ya une
fin de semaine que j'ai pris
complètement off parce que j'ai ce qui
paie les trainings parce que mais je me
blessais le jeter en achetant entre eux
n'est blessé parce que j'étais allé
faire une sorte de cave au mont
tremblant
mais bref j'ai fait ça tout au long du
mois une question ça dont je peux
comprendre
[Musique]
au moment où te dit de priest objectif
le
uk qui tue et s'est écoulé motivation et
une demande avec l'argent et fait
quelque chose qu'ils aient besoin d'un
objectif il manque quelque chose cette
école était d'esprit qui ont mené à te
dire dans quatre moore je me jette un
objectif pendant quatre sets ça a
toujours été comme ça que je fonctionne
et maintenant pour le sport j'ai
vraiment je suis pas capable de
m'entraîner juste pour m'entraîner ces
fêtes faut que je trouve un objectif
j'adore mettons aller au devant les
cours et à l'énergie j'aime l'action mai
khai pas de puces ont le fond de train
ou d'objectifs puis ça peut être des
objectifs très
des fois c'est qu'on le des fois ses
jambes elle je veux être capable d'être
capable je veux retourner être capable
de benchs et de plats et mettons le psy
parce qu'il a déjà fait depuis je veux
me prouver à moi qui sépare j'ai 30 ans
que je suis capable de faire ce type
mais j'ai toujours eu besoin d'autres
s'appuient là
je savais que
c'était un long shot courir en mode 3
heures mais que c'était quand même un
choc que j'avais dit que si je voulais
courir en vaut trois heures il ne
restait plus un million d'années
il me reste encore binbin du temps mais
ne restait plus un million d'années
considérant que je sais comment mes
genoux sont en train de déjà flanché de
ces faits que j'ai vu que j'avais pu
tant de temps devant moi pour faire ce
fait que fait que j'ai voulu j'ai voulu
le faire ce n'est pas ce que je t'ai en
bonne forme quand même heure au début
puis au début du projet puis puis j'ai
toujours aimé les corriger un moment où
est-ce que c'était la fin de notre
affaire ou c'est juste un bouton avait
pas un objectif parce que ouais c'était
la fin
ben il en fait c'est ça commençait à
être tough de motiver à cause de la
copie de l'été j'ai couru toute la cave
ils peuvent commencer à trouver le temps
long je commence à trouver qui avait
rien à faire rien qui s'en venait votre
projet vraiment et puis pas de projet de
ce sport at on fait que fait que c'est
pour ça que j'ai décidé de le faire et
en même temps je me suis dit ça fait du
contenu quand un coup aux multiples pour
les gens qui me suivent parce que je
suis un petit bout que cherchaient-ils
un peu une sélection ledent dans mes
réseaux sociaux dans le dans ma présence
sur les médias sociaux
fait que j'ai trouvé que c'était une
bonne façon de créer du contenu
interactif comme de fait c'est ce sur
quoi les gens intéressés le plus depuis
que je suis sorti du
fait que c'est ça fait que les 4 mois
passés
finalement je taleo marathon pitié des
fois des fois ça me tentait pas pantoute
le honnêtement c'est des fois ça me
tentait pas pantoute
l'horaire faisait qu'il fallait que
j'aille courir sa piste seule sphère des
intervalles à 7h30 le soir
même des fois c'était un calvaire c'est
un vrai cauchemar sauf qu'il n'y ait pas
une fois où est ce qu un finissage me
suis pas dit quand il n'y a pas une fois
parce qu un finissage me suis dit ah
j'aurais pas dû le forte pour la fox
à bord la fois que j'ai fait une sortie
qu avait même cette sortie le et
elephant quand j'ai fini j'étais allée
correct mais mon ami daumas martel puis
[ __ ] on est vraiment du fun sauf
qu'ils apprécient je me suis comme
blessé le cefic sûr que la ans en
arrivant tout après de jean le cam a cru
que great time ce téléphone et on est
allé loin
puis faites ça c'étaient ceux ci le
sirha seule chose que je n'aurais pas dû
faire ça mais encore là je le regrette
pas parce que ce téléphone mais c'est
quoi la c'est quoi la leçon que l'on
peut tirer de cette fois l'homme et on
sait qu'ils traînent limites qu'il faut
passer par la loi c'est que dans ce jeu
suivant un plan d'entraînement dans mon
plan d'entraînement et y avait pas sûr
et déjà le plan d'entraînement et amène
aux bottes cloutées si tu le fais comme
du monde hippique billet fait qui est
fait par quelqu'un qui les gîtes pour le
faire il t'amène au bout tu fais xi des
patients étudiés par toi-même d'affaires
bon mais là ils me disent courir une
heure et demie mais ce voyage va faire
deux heures et demie aujourd'hui
n'est-ce pas sur le plantier leur place
était c'était une course de deux heures
sur du plat chez les frères 12h40 dans
montagne s'est fait que c'était pas sur
le plan de ses puits le plan et amène
déjà une limite j'ai juste passé le très
chaude facture aussi c'est ça aussi
c'est une
carte humaine quand tu te mets un
objectif pas un plan pour y arriver des
fois ça sert à rien de passer des
cytises essayé de sauter et à main
vraiment y avait on est sûr je pense que
nous devons nous dire par l'état mais
sur le podcast le
même bar qui s'était pas de casque le
stelle tadjeur logan c'était le coach
georges st-pierre - sinon il m'aurait à
l'île aux pies disait à
diego lugano 4 ou jean rouger maître
d'école ils ont été libérés voyons donc
je me dis à chaque fois
pour construire le lendemain quand ils
discutent beyond faut que t'arrêtes
avant dépassé la limite exacte pour
parce que le plus important c'est la
consistance inexact c'est la chose
importante ici le fait que tu vaux bien
trop fort parce que parce que tu veux te
prouver ou parce que wade veut quelles
raisons
piqué ça fait que les trois jours a
presque pas traîner sa nuit dans ton
truc sata
6 course f les affiliés déjà
le travail et pas de genre donné tout ce
que tu as une foyer données genre
ce que tu peux donner à chaque jour pour
pouvoir donner à tous les jours d'avancé
sur une ligne droite là c'est plutôt
faire un pas en avant deux pas en
arrière noir exact c'est cette leçon là
est importante pas juste dans le sport
ou l'entraînement pour un marathon pour
lectra si tu prends la guide doit
pratiquer la guette le site arrive
qu'une journée du pratique pendant 12
heures
pique they burn out puis le lendemain
sur vous même pu voir une guitare ça
donne envie de vomir ou bien j'allais
justement de courriels répondent que non
parce que j'ai rien c'est juste la
guette la veille que je
suis à la fin de par jour à kérou les jo
que 12h12 exact exactement puis ça
évidemment
c'est difficile de faire ça c'est parce
que moi des fois dans ce programme là il
y avait des 45 minutes is it est en zone
bleue zone bleue mais peut soit 135 mais
peut soit 135 le c'est mon objectif
c'est un pays de 4 15 pour ceux qui
connaissent un peu ce soir on oublie
souvent un peu de 4,15 sur un marathon
puis des fois fallait que je courre à
5,35
pour être dans une bleue pendant 45
minutes je peux dire qu'après 45 je
n'avais pas l'impression de l'impression
de m'être levé de mon lit la peine
dans l'impression d'avoir perdu son
temps c'est frustrant à quel point des
fois faut que tu prennes les étapes une
à foix puis c'est facile dans
la monde dans lequel on vit puis je veux
qu'on touche sur ce aussi le sur les
réseaux sociaux on y parlera après après
après avoir fait le rap up de ce
parcours le mais
des fois c'est frustrant
à quel point il faut que tu te retient à
quel point ça va pas tout le taf lâcher
quand tu sois partager des images
partagées mais story des fois le ppi
souvent je n'avais pas le prix d'un gars
qui avait calé courir trois heures au
marathon selon ce qu'ont ce qu'on entend
puis j'ai eu une
olympique parce que les olympiques ça a
été pendant cette période là puis j'ai
une illumination en voyant mme hollis à
edel qui était une américaine qui est
arrivé 3ème au marathon et pl à partage
ses entraînements sur strav fait que ce
travail pour ceux qui savent pas ce
qu'est un réseau social pour les gens
qui font course vélo natation pour
pouvoir tu peux te suit voir des
trainings mortes et parcourt depuis ces
affaires-là ce
la tendance et a toujours postés tamer
bestheim tout le temps post est tombé ce
timbre que le monde par world solide 6
mai est la partage systématiquement
toutes ses courses puis
je pense je ne sont pas je pense que
c'est autour de 3 30 pour son marathon
et calefato olympiques puis acura carte
45 c course lente mais moi mes courses
lounge et cours et qu'elles ont à 4,45
les ti fleur j'ai vu ça j'ai fait ça pas
de bon sens elle sait comme elle arrive
troisième aux olympiques puis un
courlande même qu'elle est pas honteuse
de montrer ce que je me suis dit
pourquoi ce qu'un montant inscrit ses 3e
aux olympiques tu sais seul training qui
a fait le fait qu'une fois que tu
réalises site du christ est vrai que
dans le fond le remake de bonnes
semaines d'entraînement le soin et puis
de prendre
vraiment comme comme jouer de la guitare
deux heures par jour de vraiment faire
des fois c'est frustrant tellement tu
dis je pourrais en faire plus mais au
final la bonne a fort à faire et souvent
et souvent dans l'autre sens le 10
semaines à la retenue puis dans la
constance
par semaine à peu près 200 kg plus que
200 kg le seuil est de 100 kg à ses 500
miles fait que si on pourrait faire le
calcul mais c'est plus que 200 kg le
bref
bref cas qu'on dit aussi ses collègues
de prendre sa relaxe s'il est
actuellement le shérif actuellement
c'est que le procès exact chaque fois
c'est nécessaire des fois c'est
nécessaire à 100% mais pas tout le temps
on y reviendra
fait que ce soit dans le fond tout pour
dire que juste arrivé afin de vos
programmes puis une des affaires que ça
fait quand tu fais confiance au
processus
secteur confiance puis quand j'ai quand
je me suis réveillé à 5 heures le jour
la journée mon marathon et aucun doute
dans ma tête j'allais faire en bo3 et mm
pô je t'ai pas nerveux bourg se savait
que ça allait faire mal je savais que
j'allais j'allais avoir de la misère
dans le dernier 10 kilos parce que si
c'est un marathon quand même le team et
j'avais aucun doute dans ma tête puis
sur une fois que tu arrives avec cette
confiance dans une course pas grand
chose qui peut te sortir de l'outil
autant qu'un 11 points de plus je ramène
surtout tant d'autres à faire que le
sport parce que le sport est vraiment un
reflet la fois une métaphore vous
prendrez mais
nombre de fois parce que je sais pas
pour toi mais moi quand j'arrive dans un
podcast ou est-ce que j'ai le temps de
me préparer
j'ai pas mal moins nerveux que quand
j'arrive dans un podcast que j'ai comme
lui wikipedia puis georges vite fait la
veille par jean paul tu en es tu si oui
quand tu fais la préparation
après cet écart est classé comme un
examen au primaire au secondaire à
l'université un nombre de fois que tu
arrives dans les examens puis jetée luz
le début d'examen parce que c'est qu'il
n'y a aucune question qu'on peut me
poser que je serai pas répondre
surtout à l'université la liberté ça
c'est comme si tu as lu le livre je te
les bien approprié dans mon parcours
altéra tueur s'est bien repris et
l'oeuvre tu connais le courant si tu as
et aucune question à développement que
je serais pas capable de nelly et puis
facteur chance le sort est ce quelqu'un
ou la journée marathon épique facteur
chance le sait juste ton entraînement ta
forme physique
à moins que ces journées le schiphol il
arrive de coigny facettes en parle et où
il pleuve outils
d'hier explosive en plein parcours mais
encore ceux en corse la diarrhée
explosive elle arrive pas à moins que tu
pognes la gastro mettons de quelqu'un
mais la diarrhée explosive à la rive par
random la formaiton que tu manges de
cocteau pas tu t'es pas habitués à
manger avant des courses au dessus mais
l'autre c'est tout ça est un ailier de
jeu fédérer plus de risque à port une
gastro externe un mois elle plus de
risques de diarrhée explosive le pti je
savais que j'allais manger pendant ma
course je savais que j'allais manger
avant je savais que j'allais manger la
journée avant je savais que j'allais
boire c'est tout était comme c'était
comme du monde puis bref pour ceux que
ça intéresse le marathon ç'a super bien
été faite 12h58 30 avec mon objectif est
fait je pense que genre toucherait plus
un marathon pour le reste de ma vie je
pense qu'on peut dire ce web envers le
peut-être que je sais que ça va revenir
mais parce quand même ça vive sur les
articulations le cse la course la course
sur route puis après ce qui s'est passé
c'est que parce que j'ai de la misère à
dire non à ce genre de choses là je me
suis approché pour être sûr l'équipe de
le camp pour amasser des fonds pour les
enfants malades
pour le beaumont ultre qui était un 80
kilomètres en montée un bon mon la
semaine après ouais c'était pas la
meilleure idée c'était pas la meilleure
c'est pas la mer suite d'événements qui
tue et savent comment ça termine et
c'est ce qui me suivent savent comment
ça termine et ceux qui me suivent pas
que suivre ce sans filtre et
je me suis rendu à
ça allait bien pendant 35 km
je suis arrêté au 35e km il y avait une
équipe de pédiatres de l'université du
québec à trois rivières qui s'occupait
de comstar des ampoules percé tous à
pitre tp les enfants moi je pensais que
ces quelques règles mais j'ai fait de
bons mais je le vérifie quand même quand
j'ai enlevé mes bas j'ai vu que ça
allait être compliqué me rendre jusqu'à
80 kilomètres quand j'ai vu mes pieds
finalement partir non à 35,4 finalement
aux autres ils m'ont gérer ça est monté
petto depuis la sueur partie pendant à
peu près une dizaine de kilos ça c'est
ben était encore mais après si j'ai
commencé à avoir mal au coeur puis a pu
être capable de mettre la bouffe
dans mon core ppi de boire fait que
jeter tout cas de bois pin et de la
bouffe fait que si c'était à peu près
autour de six heures et demie de course
à peu près à 8 heures massa à peu près à
7h45 de course mais j'ai une crampe et
jetaient pierre derrien fort j'étais
déshydraté complètement con cossu avec
mon corps suivait plus fait que j'ai
essayé de faire un dépassement
dans une single tracks qui descendait
avec des racines des roches mais j'ai
mon petit carré d'éclairer la ligne
racines fait que j'aie trim je suis
dessus peluche tombé puis ma vision est
comme devenu tout noir puis je me suis
je me suis quand même relevé de peine et
de misère le gars derrière moi y avait
l'air vraiment inquiet
finalement j'ai marché jusqu'à jusqu'à
une rue puis j'ai appelé j'ai appelé ma
soeur qui m'amène à l'infirmerie puis
j'ai quasiment passante en infirmerie le
c'était
c'était complexe faut que j'arrête à 56
que l'homme ait finalement mais ce n'est
que partie remise pour plein de raisons
mais notamment parce que la prochaine
fois ce sera mon objectif principal sera
de faire en 81 kg puis je m'entraînerai
en conséquence mais bref on a ramassé
quand même vingt mille places pour le
camp
ce qui est ce qui est cool ce qui aura
valu la peine de
daleo puiser au fond de moi-même pendant
pendant huit heures de course à pied
c'est quand même un temps
je veux pas comprendre c'est ce qui
fonde et des 160 laitiers
jcbb le mental on va avoir justement
probablement se croisent les doigts pour
recevoir mathieu blanchard avait des
clients de parler par notre podcast avec
jean philippe brothier justement qui est
qui tarit troisième bolt roi du mont
blanc qui va peut-être pouvoir me parler
de comment comment éviter que ce qui
m'est arrivé arrive
c'est genre de
prouesse humaine même que je comprends
pas quand même quelques arguments un peu
carmen 6 puis 5 en trois sets mais un
genre c est capable de faire des
affaires dans ma maison mais et pour
venir à la préparation du marathon parce
que c'est surtout ce sera intéressant
est ce que tu disais plus le feeling est
avec est arrivé ce j'en ai le confiant
puis préféré qui comme s'ils disent
c'est une allégorie pour allegri pour un
à l'egypte au n'importe quoi n'importe
quelle chose que tout n'est pas de la
haine que tout soit un examen que ce
soit n'importe quoi c'est comme jeter
prix d'avant set et pris 4 mode avancé t
pour réveiller un mot avant pire pour
toi qui m'as marathon dans un mois faut
que je me mette en shape le thé pigeât
ça doit sûrement
arrive tout le temps fort c'est pour
n'importe quoi que j'en examen le maire
de préciser que tu dis toute la nuit
j'arrive stressé noir 1 cc cc la leçon
c'est prendre à d' avance puis fait le
travail au jour le jour sur une période
de vingt journées même toit les laisser
rentrer dans ce jeu
mais m'est arrivé je voudrais similaire
mais en musique le travailler ce n'est
qu'une tonne sur une tournée avec
narcisse tipi
jeu de la forme est là tout n'est ce pas
ce moment à la porte il faut qu'elles
soient prêtes faut qu'elle soit finie
depuis le sicom
finalement dernière mine d'or
on pensait que compter qu'on était
content que c'était fini finalement
finalement non t'es leur travail sur
l'or en urgence à stresser leur stress
et réels qu'ils finissent eux envoient
sur le finalement à pour complément
comptant le genre pourrait déjà ça a pas
si longtemps sur le tipi le feeling est
comme avoir remis quelque chose que je
peux complètement fiable et y est trop
tard je peux rien faire pigeât d'avoir
mal géré seul à voir mais plus dernières
minutes pile et que ça saute est
titulaire ce soir c'est quelque chose
qui reste pour tout le temps un
père fils pourrait jeter à ce moment le
jeter au plus beau que j'ai été depuis
est maintenant sur pie proulx finale
pour quelque chose qui est sic est là
c'est plate mais les gens pensent qu'ils
marquent la fin de la vie continue bien
maintenant que tu peux dire c'est pour
tout ça parce quelqu'un est mort lundi
soir non mais tu es au final ces gens
j'écoute la toune je trouve que la game
à la guitare à tel moment est un peu
trop fort tu sais ça au final est le
seul car dans ce jour à marseille 14e
puis c'est vraiment mais si le toit
envers toi
moi ça me fait chier
il lui fait le genre le soir matthieu
girolet imbriquent d'armes déjà dit
d'habitude je quitte en mode solution
tout en un mot d'ordre est l'auteur
showdown le secam le site est trop
complètement chad d'acheter le genre je
suis le pistachier jeu lorsque la
musique georges aucun ou que vous
sifflez c'est juste négative entre le
jeu parfait pour faire cela
plus là mais je vais soulever cette
équipe bon le mana ont fait un post
mortem de ce qu'est ce que s'est passé
pourquoi ça s'est posée de même qu'est
ce que je peux faire différent qu'est-ce
que je peux faire pour m'assurer que ça
n'arrive plus
puis
si si si
c'est maxime depuis
on a fait une autre on leur mit deux
jours d'avant son épaule content c'est
comme si on regarde ce qu'ils ont fait
un plat sur un plan très sympa d'en
faire des plats
pas continuer continue enfin plat puis
avec des objectifs réalistes avec des
deadlines au prochain deadline finale
mehdi deadline en cours de route non
pour twitter comme avoir un une attente
d'équité rendu terrain dus à la bonne
place au bon moment le petit pour
arriver au bout de la nuit finale au bon
moment c'est comme on fait sauter pistes
issues le plan
arrive à bon port puis tout a bien été
pas de stress ultime de jarret
j'ai pas de fond du baril de fer que
l'importance du plat l'otan est
organisée dans l'atteinte de ses
objectifs en fait ouais parce que si
juste avoir un objectif une date butoir
mais sans le plat qui t'amène bâtisse va
travailler justement dernières minutes
avant qu'il faut faire faut que j'en
objectif l'eau il faut que j'arrive le
puits thierry breton exact pitt il la
fameuse image de
l'objectif ou le deadline que tu vois
sur un certain palier puisque la salle a
l'air d'être une marche énorme et que
dans le fond c'est l'accumulation de
plein de petites marches ce que tu dis
là c'est tellement vrai et puis moi je
lai a pris
dans les deux dernières années c'est
quelque chose que j'ai appris ça parce
que souvent
c'est les enjeux étaient moins grand
mais ton quand je t'ai à l'école c'est
quand même tu peux des fois je choisis
mes 17 la veille piste est comme un
artiste aux bergeries moins bon mais ça
jamais vraiment eu un impact réel sur
ma vie leur dis c'est que j'allais
passer quand même j'avais continué en
forme et mémé chose sauf que dans les
dernières années en tant que travailleur
autonome entreprenant orties
y arrivait d'aidé deadline que christine
big deal
ça m'écoeure brigue ma business ou à
evreux pitt arrive la vérité comme
pétrifié de la tâche à accomplir puis de
comme le jeu placé mais depuis que j'ai
compris ceux mettant
met donc dans ta tête le un
bourdonnement incroyable de choses à
faire mais dont une toon army plus you
on n'a pas des piles drôme ont
hypothéqué la bei depuis le forfait le
mix le plus de tout ça ça devient énorme
puis ça peut te paralysé de moi ce que
je fais maintenant à chaque fois que
j'ai une journée qui est une grosse
journée c'est parce que le récemment eu
des bonnes journées au studio puis worm
parallèlement ce jeu lancé mahmoud
company ipic accompagne sans aucun autre
cas c'est vrai seulement mais
je fais juste prendre
un cahier puis j'écris je fais des tirs
est l affaire tir est à l'affût tirait
très fort parce que j'ai à faire la
journée comment parler avec yann qui
venaient me parler de sa planification
puis une fois que c'est sur papier on
dirait que mon cerveau est capable de
compartimente alizés chacune des enfants
avec le je vois la première affaire en
haut de la liste c'est genre ok faire
une soumission pour téléphone mais
faisons ce en faut peu importe comment
la liste est longue fomine je commence
le faisons ce une fois que c'est fait tu
morceaux prochaine étape pour ce
prochain et à petit morceau tout devient
vraiment plus 5 parce que c'est pas un
gros bloc c'est plusieurs petites à fond
puis ton cerveau liées au genre qui
s'était mal à faire affaire bastille
kompakt l'ampleur exacte je me souviens
de tous les enfants que j'adore je fais
pas ça sur papier saliba les jeunes
partis ton cerveau de quitter j'ai pu
besoin d'y retenir par carpi des justes
par sa leçon aux le préfet à la fois que
je les costes le dit c'est moi je suis
même pas plus pour amel zabat ce que toi
tu étais plus tdf moins de six mois je
suis 0 tdi le tiff est capable de rester
attentif vraiment longtemps une affaire
sans sans changer d des fake je peux
même pas comprendre comment quelqu'un
qui a un déficit d'attention peut
fonctionner sans faire de liste parce
que moi j'en fais quand même six mois je
augmente tout dans ma tête parce que
sinon même moi je me perds c'est dans
toutes ces idées là le
bon métier moi j'ai pas eu la
confirmation que je pourrais
éventuellement des professionnels qui
était juste de tout juste prêté jusqu à
elecam enfants
jusqu'à élèves dans l'une
face et peut dire que jeter des oeufs
puis puis même affaire c'est que tu es
moi ça fait l'otage travail autonome
fait dizaine d'années
la difficulté d'un homme c'est que
souvent pas de routine les journées sont
un terrain d autres
puissent se s'étoffe pour justement
faire ce travail régulier le qu'on parle
qu'il faut faire pour s'en aller
quelques pas
puis moi j'ai aussi la tendance à mon
mauvais lot des besoins de trop d'avoir
un piquant dans le trouble
s'est teinté c'est avec ces mots le défi
c'est de diminuer un groupe une foutue
diminue que les résultats de fois libre
où du temps de
ben et le tempérament d'organiser
d'affaires de base la ville gentil
fantôme ménages primo ce marathon ménage
ça fait d'un ménage obstat atome pee wee
en même temps rennes puis laisser comme
qui est organisée à prendre le temps
d'organiser dans la course c'est ce que
les gens oublient djaffar de pas le
temps de te faire la liste pourtant
faire toutes les tâches que tu viens
impie vit-il problèmes ou si je pense
que téléphone à la paralysie des ports
falsafa c'est le stress que ses joueuses
le
ta porte puis le au lieu de faire des
choses belles le sait comme la paralysie
du stress de stoke city puis dans
l'ordre un cercle vicieux puisque le
titre est parfois avec d'autres encore
payer puis le thé tout se jouait un même
lot just et
ses genres
gens quelqu'un qui te demander ce
périple en lice marc genre guide pour
combattre le stress de toutes les choses
que tu as à faire puis ces genres you
believe you listening se marre qui
complique de tasci mois
c'est un peu ça paraît si stressée par
un million d'affaires
ben oui c'est ça c'était si stressée
parce que tu es petit détour en examen
se peut que tu dis
exact peu importe quoi mais ce
standard ans piste est organisé mais le
déni c'est quelque chose on estime ses
créations aux écoutes déni mais oui
maison mais ce mec c'est
celle-là je pense que si on sur le come
back au début de la conversation
tu peux pas vraiment être en déni si tu
mets albert ton objectif mettons ou
tonton dead line ou que tu entends par
là des gens qui pilote porte garant de
ton deadline si tu peux pas tu peux pas
nier le quinqua quand je veux nier c'est
moi ça m'est arrivé des fois de me lever
puis de me dire pendant le processus
jusqu'au marathon de me dire pas grave
si je vois pas aujourd'hui qu'on se pose
pas grave ça va bien aller au marathon
quand même eu le dessus sauf que parce
que
je vous savez qu'il fallait que je fasse
une story fallait que le monde roman que
je monte au monde mais je pouvais pas
juste
à rentrer dans ce patelin où prendre ce
y loti avec eux je reste sa route dit il
ya deux choses que quelques jours
n'était pas allé quand et comment
détruire your grave d'y aller parce
qu'en ce moment c'est vraiment
objectivement la meilleure décision que
je peux prendre pour atteindre
l'objectif de poids y aller
puis c'est la méthode la bonne raison
d'une météo si c'est dur de savoir pour
y aller pas s'attendre poste journée le
puits alors c'est fatigués ou ivoire je
peux ben payal une fois c'est pas grave
dans tout ça c'est comme la mauvaise
retombe pas y aller piquer les deux sont
possibles qui
justement dans
ce soit il faut savoir différencier le
c'est vraiment la meilleure décision que
je peux prendre ce principal axe versus
le
port phase q3
ouais c'est ça ouais mais plus souvent
qu'autrement ce vase y rencontre amassé
l'option sa tendre moitié c'est mon
physio qui m'a dit le trois jours off le
passé comme le thé sauter fierté jambes
sont des quads sont finies
[Musique]
et non une autre affaire que je voulais
qu'on parle qui a été que j'ai
beaucoup réfléchi dans le dernier cas
moi beaucoup réfléchi par le mandant
dernières années aussi on a reparlé des
gens sans peas et
ne porter une attention particulière à
qu'est ce qui te besoin d'entendre
qu'est ce qui te fait du bien
puis d'entourer le temps touré 2-1 de
gens qui pensent comme ça
mais aussi de suivre des personnes parce
que tout le monde suit sur les médias
sociaux ont suivi des gens tout le monde
qui t'écoutent le sans-fil suils sans
filtre sauf là au delà du super c'est
la-dessus personne je pense qu'il doit
de suivre moi je pense qu'il ya un genre
de je suis contre le ce qui s'appelle
simon mai mais de toute façon même si
l'issue personne sait mais on est tout
de même su personnes sur instagram
t'écoute des podcasts des shows télé tu
t'es suis de l'amuser pas complètement
coupée des eaux du mono c'est ça puis on
a vraiment le pouvoir de suivre qui on
veut puisque ça peut paraître leur
vieillesse comme statements mais
j'aurais vraiment aimé se comprendre
plutôt thé parce que surtout début de la
pandémie comme
il ya eu comme un espèce de
de remous sur les médias sociaux puis
quelle heure on dirait que tout vrai
qu'on joue vraiment celle sur instagram
public c'était juste des affaires qui me
créer de l'anxiété qui me faisait que je
me sentais pas bien que ça m'amenait pas
un autre niveau depuis que chaque matin
je me levais c'était quand même
jardé des publications vraiment et
qui me rejoignait pas du tout
quand j'ai compris qu'au final je
terrain en photo ou un ied de ne plus
voir ces publications là qui m'amenait
kiki qui me convenait pas ça a tout
changé c'est de tout changer
je vous donne un exemple puis je pense
que j'en ai déjà parlé de cet exemple
sur le sur le podcast mais c'est un
exemple
dans une journée qui dans j'ouvre mon
cell puis le geste rôle sur mon fait
d'actualité sur instagram
pleut je vois une publication de droite
dwayne jones
fils à dwayne johnson et au jam le
dimanche jeter c'est un dimanche puis le
mouchoir shinobi lui il y est ogm
couvert de sueur parce que il y aura de
faire 100 degrés celsius dans son dans
son jean me plaît dit
que lui qui va s'entraîner le dimanche
il ya l'impression de prendre de
l'avancé
l'impression de prendre de l avance
pythie sais pas si quelqu'un en
particulier pas prendre de l'avancé sur
ma compétition juste je prend de
l'avancé
sur mon parcours sur moi pendant qu'une
version potentiel de moi mange des golfs
puits et cours de football que la
journée moi je me suis levé un matin je
prends de l'avant sur cette version la
moitié le moi je vois ce que je fais à
l'univers parallèle de roxy genre en
inde ou d'incident soi-disant qui majore
le fait que la mode je vois ce semonce
ils n'ont même pas c'est peut-être même
de rock qui est aussi performante
mais l'huile dimanche 16h au club qui
est aussi performant dimanche lui
sandrine petit les machines aux cheveux
y est georges ça y est
pis le la publication tout de suite
après c'est un con je me rappelle
pourquoi je suis content l'homme et 50
genre de
dewerdt naissent de ces guerriers qui
tout à fait les jets chaussures pourpre
une personne mais ce que cette gc
arrêtons glorifier le node est off le
fameux no df l'outil des entrepreneurs
le hashtag naudé of le tipi tout ce que
moi je vois ce qui
les fait que ces supposés faire sur les
gens vers kiss est destiné le stop glory
fine nos des offres selligent j'imagine
qu'ils ont de l'anxiété avoir le fameux
no des offres 26 ski pas du tout mon
coeur parce que moi au contraire avoir
de work qui dit je ne prends pas des
offres le dimanche
sam
sam élèves ça fait que j'ai envie d'y
aller puis est pas une fois que je vais
y aller que je vais regretter ce qui
fait que c'est là que j'ai réalisé que
deux rocs son contenu ce pourquoi il
fait ça me rejoint vraiment puis l'autre
con qui est super les jeep pour
chaussures pleines gens me rejoint pas
du tout fait que j'ai les justes en
photo puis j'ai fait ce travail là
chaque fois que je voyais quelque chose
comme ce qui me réjouit mais pas qui
m'amenait pas à me dépasser que mam
n'est pas à moi même me sentir mieux je
le suis j'arrêtais le souhaitent
puissent en est résulté en est résulté
sané culte et
un environnement
sain pour tous le médias sociaux sein
qui m'amène à être une mère personnes
selon mon échelle de valeur
chacun à son échelle de valeur chacun et
une meilleure personne selon ce qu'ils
veulent chacun peut avoir
de l'anxiété par rapport à x ou y à
faire chacun peut ne pas vouloir voir
telle ou telle affaire mais
faut être conscient des crises que nous
on veut puis d'aller d'aller chercher
ses enfants oui mais complètement 100%
d'accord avec toi puisque la morale si
ce rôle c'est qu'il ya pas un discours
qui est bon pour tout le monde non
exactes pas une approche qui est bonne
pour tout le monde y en a qui ont besoin
d'entendre explique ont besoin
d'entendre y en a qui sont à la place y
dans leur vie qu'ils voudraient ex
soviétiques ou du cad en extérieur
depuis et vice versa puis
pis pour ceux que des fois je les
besoins qu'on critique
tel type de discours
les types de discours le est important
pour certaines personnes qui posent pour
d'autres non puis autant que toi
tu étais le test assez intelligents pour
comprendre qu'ils émettront la page
mettons l'exemple de la page de wayne
est ce que je suis a fait bien du bon et
nécessaire est nécessaire je lui mets
demande est importante
mais pas pour toi parce que tu vois ce
discours le être joints pop et aline et
iic relancer en l'anxiété puis son
objectif c'est par le contrat mais bon
aloi tweet créer de l'anxiété
puis encore une fois vice versa mais toi
tu
tu critique pas cette page lanza
que des 4,4 rigueur ou quelques tics ou
peu importe quoi et pour n'importe
quelle critique que tu peux y donner
parce que tu comprends qui est bonne
pour certaines personnes c'est bercy
sera exempt pipi c'est souvent sur
l'émotion son bain des enfants qui comme
sa pile à défaut la lettre les termes de
perception bluff donne un exemple
vraiment concret mais ton
ses jantes les boutiques il n'y eut pas
de casque
moi comme angers perçoit cette
conversation au lieu
c'est quelqu'un qui
qui a été du moins d'en bas de sa vie
vraiment vraiment un temps
d'entraînement
peut-être possiblement selon mais mon
échelle absorbé dans leur traumato noter
que c'était plus nécessairement simple
que le moi j'ai trouvé que le podcast le
c'était vraiment quelqu'un qui avait qui
avait
travaillé pour essayer de trouver une
balance dans toute l'histoire de sa vie
qui fait du sens qui fait sens pour lui
qui est saine moi je trouve que c'est
super simple outil de la manière qu'ils
approchaient se puisse y amener
certaines limites qui souhaitait y
intervient certains très choquée que moi
je vois pas dépasser parce que ça ça me
coûte trop chacun qui parlait de 10,4
intéressant qui est important de garder
du temps pour la famille cabestan pour
la dialyse tempe au pc pim et on
ma blonde c'est quelqu'un qui travaille
beaucoup qui sera beaucoup plus une
création tu es un peu comme l'outil
s'écouter le podcast les saia fait
vraiment du bien et a fait foule de bien
passer du roi tu es peut-être que j'ai
pas besoin d'être tout le temps à fond
la caisse pis je peux quand même des
genres
fumée mon cigare le petit galli
l'exemple que j'en fais des élections
qui donnait outils bon verre de vin
mardi soir puisque rec tipi ces deux
jeux plus face que je fais l'homme est
riche peut obliger des mets de la
pression puissant tir de la culpabilité
à fond qu'un cache pas quelque chose
puis de soutien puis elle s'appelle
foule du bien aux casques bleus mais je
le sais pour un faible sentiment qu'ils
ont écrits kanak n'aura pas fait bientôt
quatre ans parce que on parlait de
justement du sentiment de se sentir
coupables ont fait pas quelque chose qui
sentiment qu'on sent qu'ils répliquent
et légitime puis quand on a le droit de
communiquer parce qu'ils pensent que
leur saint patron le rsa puis d'autres
ça leur peau fait du bien comme ça fait
bien blonde fac morale de l'histoire
chapeau de fait être le même sinon le
tempo le départ puis tant mieux à succès
a fait du bien d'entendre ce discours
l'aube sa vision à lui
puis ceux qui ça rejoint pau ceux qui
ont besoin d'entendre autre chose mais
ce n'est pas bien raide et l'écouté pour
arrêter même si nombreux podcasts
justice chateaufort gic star ait de
l'écouté si t'es pas de bien patrick
arnaud nom exact c'est sur exactement
puis c'est tellement c'est tellement
vrai ce que tu dis là puis c'est juste
jean prévost utilisent moins cendres est
que ces serrures qui m'appelle play m'a
appelé il fait même le centre québec
j'écoutais ce podcast le pays il m'a
vraiment aidé parce que lui aussi est là
dedans tu y es dans toute cette
balance et toutes ces affaires lançant
puis il ça m'a vraiment aidé ce podcast
l'appui comme de fait c'est peut-être le
podcast ou ce qu'on a reçu le plus de
commentaires pas le poids de paul
laporte qu'est ce qu'on aurait plus de
40 ans n'ont pas qu'à ce qui est quand
même et il s'en est pas laissé là bas il
ya beaucoup de monde qui nous ont écrit
qu'ils ont pas aimé qu'ils ont trouvé ça
tof à écouter mais en même temps long du
sihh qui s'est souvent ses commandes à
léon bollée de narita c'est sur le
positif et le négatif ça veut dire que
clairement on touche à quelque chose qui
qui est sensé mais qui est important
puisque 60 rejoint vraiment où vraiment
beau
faut juste qu'il faut juste en ait
conscience faut être conscient de
qu'est-ce qu'on a besoin d'entendre
qu'est ce qui te fait du bien qu est ce
qui t'amène à être une meilleure
personne qui t'entoure et te ces mêmes
principes aussi sur les relations
interpersonnelles le dessus parce que
oui les médias sociaux comme un reflet
de la société sauf que en même temps
quelqu'un avec qui tu t'entends taureau
puis les project entreprend puis si
nécessaire de savoir
qui était
qu'est-ce qui vote élevées dans le fond
qui vote élevées par la direction que tu
souhaites à être élevés qui va qui va
t'amener dans la direction qui va aider
à aller dans cette direction de
[Musique]
c'est de le trouver
c'est je le trouvais
de trouver moi je suis reçue par les
deux inspecteurs qui avec
ses quelque chose que je réalise puisque
jeu qui comme une évidence en fait le
meetic je parlais de de relations
attelage avec une amie seppi
le bus pour
ces quatre ans quand quelqu'un mais tant
qu'il ya des frictions que ça marche pas
l'autre table sénat ou tout actionnaire
à l'autre
le bus pas de changer une tuile bus pour
être moulés à ce que nos personnes jeudi
soit et vice versa pour qui ça
fonctionne ne trouvez quelqu'un que la
personne qui était avec tes qualités
défauts
tarif d'un même
pythie des fautes et des fautes et très
personnalités traits de caractère ou tes
habitudes wherever
comme qui sont là certaines personnes ça
pourrait vraiment légaux c'est vraiment
laid tu es gay je réellement être
compatibles vraiment pas marcher nouveau
des valeurs et arrive à quelqu'un ces
personnes il y voit même pas parce que
c'est même pas quelque chose qui est
proche a dérangé vice versa ici tu
transmets cry cry prix j'aurais parfait
peut des fois il faut vraiment qu'il va
demander qui ont des vrais riches ou sur
lesquels travaillent hors course mais
mais je pense vraiment qu'ils aient
si
c'est une question de sites questions du
site c'est
d'abord et avant tout lundi
comme c'est une question de suite
sur le contenu qu'ils consomment sur le
dépendamment de quitter débordement des
valeurs dépendamment de
truites bons films ont fait un bond à
celui trouvé le mont fait un carton avec
qui partager ta vie ouais c'est clair
puis
sutil ya des affaires qui sont
catégoriques ces méthodes et décidé
qu'il n'y a pas même pas matière à
discussion le tir mais
dans la grande majorité des que ya pas
une pensée unique sur
sur une façon de voir la vie mettons
dans la grande majorité des kurdes qui
fait si
tu penses qu'un sujet une pensée unique
probablement que trompe
amont et sociaux ces grandes affaires le
catégorique le tuer
tout suspense mettons le que
méthode comprend la politique comme
exemple
si tu penses que
québec solidaire ont la seule
vraie façon
de diriger un pays où où le québec battu
trompent parce que c'est posterez même
inversement si tu penses que la caq
qu'on la seule vraie façon diriger le
pays où le québec c'est pas vrai tout
l'été tout se trouve que le parti
conservateur démontre la seule vraie
façon des mots s'il pense honnêtement
puis c'est là qu'on fait notre pamphlet
pour véritable mais mettez tout est une
question
de perception de qu'est ce que tu vois
comme dans le futur pour toi ou pour le
québec que pour le projet t il au rio
pas de penser uniquement à part votre
affaire catégorique qui sont évidentes
le tuer mais mais c'est pas pour les
affaires qui sont
mesurables et exacte objective c'est
exact exact
mais
la politique par exemple deux fois puis
lorsque je pousse notre
égard du sujet mais c'est pas grave
la politique par exemple team et on
attend le troisième ligne c'est une
juste issue
un des
bo2 valeur ceux des baux de
vision puis tout le monde a raison mais
c'est juste non sécurisé là où ses
calculs heures kaiser ses calculs ces
calculs heures par des scientifiques
peuvent faire c'était de projectiles ont
fait en fait et l'on fit qui ont déclaré
que c'était pas un projet viable pour
autant au niveau environnemental qu'au
niveau de du transport ça a été fait ce
travail là pour juger que c'était pas
viable donc après ceux ci un entêtement
à le faire si c'est pas une opinion le
cska mais il ya des faits qui ont été
mis de l'avant puis les faits font que
disent que c'est pas une bonne idée
c'est pas une bonne idée c'est comme
pour tout que des fèves mesurable qui
dit que c'est pas une bombe brune bundle
c'est ce que je voulais en venir pileux
dans d&co justement comme ce téléthon le
jan il y aurait un particulier raison
quand il ya un consensus consensus
scientifique fou dans une direction
mais ça vaut peut-être pas un problème
pendant deux ou trois ans mais après 5
10 en examen comme c était
dur dur à débattre aussi dur
argumentaire précis mais deux sessions
prend de quoi qui est pas comme ça mais
ton et
le taux d'imposition le tir dont est-ce
qu'on impose plus les riches ou moins il
était pilote tu vas voir deux
économistes voir avec des visions
différentes de comment faire rouler
l'économie qui vont dans le fossé de la
différence de base la droite la gauche
les mets qui vont débattre de façon
nuancée mais sur la vision qu'ils ont
d'une société mettons et c'est que ce
c'est pas une vision unique de comme fo
on veut imposer lire et je sois mais
inversement peut-être qu'il y en a qui
vont s'en aller et puis peut-être que tu
vas créer un problème de l'autre bord
puis s'était tout ça c'est comme
complexe et complexe le tiff et si tu
penses que tu as la solution miracle le
problème en pop si tu penses que ta
vision pour des affaires je t'aime comme
le node est off je pense que ta vision
c'est la seule vision non mais n'a
d'autre n'a d'autre puisque toi te fait
pas du bien et peuvent sûrement dû me à
quelqu'un d'autre mais ceux là dessus on
s'entend ça c'est sûr que si on est tout
différent
sur qu'est ce qui nous
dérange que cela ne dérange pas si on
était de faire au niveau des balles
rondes différents niveaux de justement
qu'est-ce qu'on a besoin d'entendre
qu'est-ce qu'on n'a pas envie d'entendre
qu'est ce qu'on trouve drôle qu'est ce
qu'on trouve pas drôle tout ceci c'est
vraiment subjectif une fin qui est fait
je pense qu'il faut comme ramener c'est
un peu
le
l'idée que
une diversité des idées peuvent
coexister puis peuvent convenir à une
diversité personnes charest choisit sa
niche là dedans tout le monde est
content 3 10e mais
c'est l'autre jour on allait super
jeune homme toi intérêts spéciaux
pis ils ont parlé de
réduction le conte et kenzy en général
sur les relations générales mettons le
cpie différents modèles de rations plus
je me souviens que
à critiquer certains types de modèles
mettant plus
traditionnels dont des relations de
femmes
pitié
nous on était comme
oui mais si les deux là convient que ce
modèle de clé de son heureux là dedans
je comprends même sens que regarder pour
qu'elles ont aidé les autres choisissent
impies
quelle dynamique
puis à fait oui
mais en même temps
c'est quoi l'idéal c'est maintenant
c'est quoi l'idée à la pression il peut
être abordée mais c'est quoi le
qu'est-ce qu'on veut que ce soit la
règle qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qu'on
voudrait qu'il soit l'exception essayer
quand même quelque chose qu'est ce qu'on
voudrait
que en général la société ça soit la
norme qu'est ce qui sera optimale
mettons du
puy ce parement aussi qui sait quand
même un peu démontrable c'est comme
étant le niveau moyen de bonheur le plus
élevé chez eux une société où met-on
les femmes puis les hommes travaillent
autant versus une société où les hommes
travaillent puis fin de ta maison
price est calculable aussi
fac situe juste une question de choix
personnel où il y en a ou
you qu'est ce qu'en tant que société on
décide qu'il modèle qui fonctionne le
mieux en général
je crois que c'est des choix personnels
dans la société dans laquelle on était
fake mettons que face aux foreurs dit
justement avec des ouvrages comme comme
celui des médias sur les relations
toxiques avec l'apprentissage avec les
films qui changerait éventuellement
potentiellement que de moins en moins de
gens vont choisir une relation où il ya
un déséquilibre
financier ou de pouvoir ou un peu
importe comment on peut on peut le
définir le fait que potentiellement la
société votre tranquillement changer
mais on peut pas demander à quelqu'un
qui a grandi avec
dans la société dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui qui pour cette personne le
choisit une relation où est-ce que j'ai
pas de leur donner un exemple vraiment
caricatural ou sql mais l'homme est
pourvoyeur piquer la femme est là la
princesse à la maison mais dont le tuer
le jeu prend vraiment de quoi de
complètement caricaturé le messie pour
cette fille là aussi pour ceux gueule
cette relation là parce qu'ils y ont
grandi dans la société dans laquelle ils
sont si ce qu'il est les plus heureux
ben c'est un choix personnel c'est après
ça on peut vouloir que la société
devienne
à et dans une autre direction sauf que
ça va se faire en changeant
ce qu'on consomme en changeant ce qu'on
produit puis éventuellement ce qui va
faire plaisir à cette fille là je
demande qui dans cette relation là mais
peut-être que ça va devenir autre chose
dans dix ans ce congrès en fait que je
pense que c'est des choix personnels où
on se trouve présentement mais pour que
ça change je mets ton si on s'aperçoit
que objectivement mettons ces minutes et
le type de modèle
faut critiquer l'ancien maintenant comme
les critiquer mais sans casse qui
critiquez sans critiquer ceux qui
prennent le choix de le pays vive le
tcc comme on peut on peut critiquer
mettons là on se rend compte de plus en
plus que
un modèle de coupe traditionnelle ça
fonctionne pas mais tant pis quand on
tend de plus en plus vers un coût
puisque le dialogue est ouvert sur la
police à moto ont été on en parle de
plus en plus
mais jamais on va emmener à
critiquer quelqu'un qui dit ben moi un
être humain ça m'intéresse pas pantoute
lundi on en arrivera pas là sauf qu'on
peut commencer à ouvrir le dialogue dans
l'autre sens devrait peut-être que le
modèle traditionnel et paul bon on fait
que tu critique le modèle mais ceux qui
adhèrent à ce modèle là parce que c'est
ce qui pour l'instant leur convient le
mieux je peux pas critiquer ces gens là
dessus je pense que le changement se
fait doit se faire dans le temps mais
après ça je pense que c'est si des choix
personnels selon la société dans lequel
tu es tu
si t'es pas un accord que le choix de
quelqu'un tu peux aussi que
dans le fond le way nicole dit le biais
moi ça vaut moins que ça va bien ça va
bien je me disais justement en fait
s'ils avaient fait s'ils avaient
vraiment en fait une pensée comme unique
certitude les causes y
en deuil il a les yeux
mais ç'a toujours été tués mais le sait
mais wow je m'entends vraiment avec
l'écho en fête mais
bref en fait je me suis ce que je me dis
c'est que s'il y avait vraiment de
pensée unique qui fonctionne tout le
temps à serait tout le temps d'adopter
en fait c'est autant politique que dans
ta vie personnelle dans tes relations
this is étaient unanimes genre que le
couple ouvert c'était la meilleure
affaire ça serait juste si on était
toutes pareilles vraiment pareil ce
serait facile dans l'airé de recettes
claira à suivre c'est que ce soit sur ce
que ça marche on le trouvait mais on
n'est pas d'autre part et c'est ça la
force afin
t'avais dessus
on ne traite toutes les points cette
fois on a fait tout les points ça peut
être un podcast plus cool c'est pas de
cas cela qu'on fait à deux il ya vu une
coupe d'affaires voulait frapper parce
que des affaires et puis dites nous si
vous avez dites nous si vous avez aimé
c'est une conversation de même à 2 +
plus qu'à jouer comporte un peu d'une
expérience personnelle qu'on élabore
sont des points qu'on
qu'on veut réfléchir avec zoom dans le
fond du ketin notre réflexion est tout
le temps en continu le ici au sans fil
mais mettons t-il de mais tant qu'on
fait la conclusion tout atteindre un
objectif de convier
c'est quoi le consens qu'on atteindra
son objectif mais ton
cecileb le meilleur la mer sensation
monde entier puis je l'avais oublié
parce que ça faisait vraiment longtemps
est témoin d'un niveau de point de vue
sport le témoin jeu ça fait le
savoir-faire 55 je fais plus de natation
de haut niveau puis moi je
fonctionnellement un petit succès quand
tu fais ton objectif
après avoir mis toutes les efforts puis
avoir réussi sur du long du extra long
terme des mois depuis je rentre à
l'université que je dis je veux gagner
les championnats canadiens
universitaires
cas chaque année ça marche pas je donc
pas quelque chose qui arrive puis vu que
ma dernière année je les gants
après cinq ans à vouloir le phare
permettre tout en oeuvre pour le faire
puis d affaires hors de mon contrôle qui
se passait pour que ça arrive paul
mais arrivée afin de type de faro
les u depuis leur camp j'arrivais j'ai
franchi le fil d'arrivée puis j'ai vu 2
58 30
mais j'étais
rempli de fierté de bonheur de le
sentiment d'accomplissement
puis-je te défoncer le secteur et donner
tout mon effectif
ça faisait trois ans que je courais
comme un mongol santé toutes ces
émotions ont lieu malgré le fait que tu
es en train de pisser dessus et le fait
que je traîne ça c'est la plus grande
fierté tout en tissant dessus j'étais
incertain madame qui est venue
m'interviewer parce que je trouvais
deuxième place à savais que j'avais fait
pour des faits qu'elle voulait a voulu
que je parle un peu de ce puits jeter un
déchet humain et le jeter par terre je
n'ai pas de me relever mais
mend cité c'est un drôle de feeling
parce que
moi j'étais vraiment faire envers moi
même mais on dirait que
c'est là que c'est là que j'ai senti en
fait que depuis que sortie d'eau des
puits que j'ai une tribune c'est là que
j'ai senti on dirait que ma tribune
comme
été la plus positive pour moi parce que
j'ai reçus en et demain
400 messages
privés j'ai dit pas tout l'ouvreur je
n'ai pas tout lu parce que c'est
vraiment beaucoup de messages mais j'ai
honnêtement reçues 400 messages de
personnes oui certaines personnes que je
connais même des personnes qui ont suivi
le parcours qui m'écrivait en disant un
badaud et
félicitations pour ça c'était vraiment
incroyable de parcours puis badauds et
j'aime courir mon premier 5 km petite
histoire ils m'ont vraiment aidé j'aime
courir mon pays j'ai reçus parce que là
c'est les courses d'automne était hier
il y avait le marathon de deux grandes
baies puis avait plusieurs épreuves il
ya plein de monde qui m'envoie une photo
une selphy deux autres qui venaient de
faire leurs premiers disent leur premier
21 points à leur premier cinq premiers
marathons qui ont dit en voyant testory
j'étais comme ça me motive à y aller
puis en sortant mon marathon j'ai pris
mon seul rêve est d'aller en finale
assis et j'ai réussi deux ans 58 dati ce
genre je suis vraiment content que les
gersois vrai que 400 messages 22
personnes puis pas pour ce jeu les fêtes
je les fais tu pour moi en premier mais
mène c'est le fun en tabarnak de voir
que du monde qui m'ont suivi là dedans
puis que du monde qu'ils étaient fiers
aussi du monde que eux ça les a amené à
s'améliorer et à être une meilleure
version de même à challenger défi c'est
juste positif c'est juste comme au stift
aux chocs rogers de positif c'est comme
si c'est le fun de voir que ce soit ça
peut être aussi pour avoir des
félicitations peu juste pour superman
c'est ceux à fort que toi tu attires ce
pic à toi c'est comme
toi tu étais comme
positif très souvent quand on dit le
mode histoire ressemble des métaux ce
qui coûterait par le sans fil tu nous
ressentons nous ressembler quand même un
métier les commentaires qu'on reçoit
même des commentaires qui sont en
désaccord avec ce qu'on dise ça nous
ressemble pareil d'armagnac et c'était
kirill était sauf exception mais en
général mais
factice quand tu donnes positif quand tu
reyel le positif par toi aussi s'est
fixé comme dell belle leçon le temps
sans parler des carmes ou de cycle est
tout sauf à l'otsi que l'homme était un
sait s'il veut pas site attire aussi ce
que tu aimes tu es moins exacts pitot
raison que de que de voir ce
ça fait que j'ai vraiment une relation
plus saine mais ton
depuis depuis les cinq derniers mois je
vends une relation plus saine avec mon
cellulaire avec les gens qui me suivent
puis mon interaction avec tout seul et
tu pas eu peu pitié en plus en plus si
j'arrivais ma tante et qui
suit les affaires on voit l'afrique et
qu'on n'est pas d'accord ça nous forge
un peu envie de répondre on répond
faculty comme un peu fâché tu réponds
quelque chose qui le monde décrit par
sont pas d'accord ce que tu as dit plus
finalement ce n'est pas
si
négative en place et la colère ça c'est
jamais bon incroyable c'est pas un
centime en soit cette fois qui c'est une
émotion qui humaines puis normal mais je
pense le moins voilà cultive le mieux on
se porte mois puis une affaire ausssi
prenaient le temps d'écrire
à des gens qui vous élève
pour leur dire qui vous élève parce que
ça fait toute la différence le jeu du
temps en temps quelqu'un qui a quand
même bon fort loin glci chaque fois
qu'il ya un message qui mérite un
message qui me parvient jusqu'à -
il n'y a pas une journée parce que j'ai
pas un doute sur genre
bien sûr sur la tribune kg puis ces
choses là puis à chaque fois je reçois
un message
c'est tout le temps mais ça fait ma
journée vous êtes allés aussi sam élèves
aussi exact prenez le temps farce puis
c'est ça je pense que oui
merci la gagne écoutez question jean
renoir question qui a reçu le lendemain
le lendemain et à peine un objectif là
dessus un blues post objectif non non je
suis sonné depuis dans le fond c'est
juste rails depuis j'ai pensé à toi de
bromont est fait mais je suis quand même
sur un rail depuis sorti le jeu me
laisse un peu le temps de décanter puis
je suis déjà en train de planifier
peut-être mai prochain mon prochain
target je me laisse le temps de faire un
peu de jeu me donne un genre de deux
mois pour faire une jarre de rotation
course natation muscu et jaugeant fin un
jour de chaque en alternance tout le
temps comme le jugement vos jim tantôt
pour faire de la muscu fait je me donne
deux mois pour reprendre un petit peu de
masse musculaire ce que veut pas même
j'en ai vraiment perdu puis jeu multi
jeux sont au fait des travaux ici même
je serai prêt de lever des affaires et
c'est aussi tout le genre sera panier
des 46 pts fait que fait que je me
laisse deux mois puis après ça j'ai une
bonne idée de ce qu'il va faire après
mais je vois je vois l'annoncé entendu
et adopté un objectif que sa vie
ben moi je suis dans le
le dernier les derniers milles de la
création de l'album avec je commence mon
objectif principal cette seule de
l'année comme dans un mois avec et avec
ariane leroy dans le match et la musique
et c'est ça c'est quelque chose comment
ça a été vraiment un travail de longue
haleine depuis plus longtemps il a déçu
depuis le sait depuis le début ou est ce
que c'était
vraiment
les premiers balbutiements des ailes qui
crie thonon et regardent ensemble on les
travaille à
notamment ont créé des maquettes des
tonneaux pression on va en studio on a
juste le drame la baisse c'est comme si
c'est tantôt non juste les instruments
non non et encore non agissent les voir
on travaille ça on essaye d affaires
vac c'est ce soir au travail qui qui
bientôt va se terminer puis j'ai
l'impression que la journée ou à ce
qu'on veut comme par qui c'est fini je
sais
ça fait tellement longtemps et a monté
un long processus pour une au travail
puis un beau travail mais avec son lot
de stress d'un an ou des difficultés son
lot d'apprentissage aussi une vraie
malle fait que
fixer certains objectifs métiers des
objets c'est fait il ya la plage de le
studio ici c'est un objectif le tpiy
on m'a fait le même travail on se fait
un terrain plat le fait qu'ils se soient
ceux se ses hôtels deadline cécité une
prochaine on va construire un mur ici il
faut prévoir sur l'état pour l'amener à
sous pour hervé le jour j après dix
points pour se réveiller la veille par
faute faut que je construise armure
d'amendé pour avoir tagué
objectif puis
[Musique]
il y en a comme
plusieurs en même temps de mener de
front
qui
sait le faire
mais je pense que
ça aille vite et on a parlé beaucoup de
poids mais dans le fond c'est sûr de
commandes il se passer le sport ça c'est
là c'est le microcosme la vie celle ci
on peut remplacer marathon par n'importe
quoi n'importe qui c'est le même même
travail même cheminement pis
ça peut vous motiver et genre qui nous
écoute pour vous motiver mais vous vous
donner le goût de vous mettre un
objectif sont injustes dont moins de
lipides de 9,2 nommé de le nommer de
site et de le porter fièrement ne
portait fièrement votre objectif sur
vaud manquent pas de faire un plan de
suivi je pense à plus juste est donc peu
importe c'est quoi un christ et on
ne découvre les villeneuve a fait ben
oui c'est maintenant qu'on nous annonce
qu'on donne des conférences de couches
de vie là dessus le titre gap paquet non
c'est un chanteur décalé qui fait le
genre de la musique est un peu
quétaine assumer
années 80
george la pire coupe longueuil c'est
vraiment drôle vraiment bon c'est une
s'appelle coach de vie drake
et quand je dis merci a bientot la gare
ouais merci beaucoup puis tenu un
commentaire si vous avez monsieur ce
genre de podcasts l'appui on aime mon
bon monsieur s arrête merci à
aa2 du contenu excellente offre tout un
tas de cartes conviendra oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur le patriote le pitch vous abonner
pour trop de leur part mme otis outre au
delà ouais trois pièces par horace par
mois et vous avez les podcasts en avance
acquise avec les premiers de votre
groupe d'amis à recruter les podcasts
qu'ils allaient avoir pouvoir avoir une
avance quand vous allez tirer la
dynamique entre les amis de tout le
temps avec une avance sur les jobs en
avance les entre deux toits mais avec
pétillante une avance sur l'humanité
complète en plus en plus parce que laure
chez le podcast fini voulu nous entendre
jazz ou davantage on fait des encore
moins de filtres à préchac podcasts etc
là on vient de finir de tourner le
podcast on va en jaser on va te filer
nicole non on y colle il est maintenant
évident comme un fils travaille la place
travot de taza taille est là mais on
jase on parle de conversion qu'on m'aide
à voir mais ce si vous voulez avoir
accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pet ul il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous